let's now see if we can balance a
chemical equation with slightly more
complex molecules so here we have a
chemical equation describing a chemical
reaction this is actually a combustion
reaction you have a some ethylene right
over here in the presence of oxygen and
you need to get a little bit of energy
to get this going but then you're going
to have this reaction that's actually
going to release energy as well but
we're not we're not accounting for the
energy at least the way we've written
right over here you have some ethylene
and this this little gene parenthesis
says it's in the gas form or gaseous
form so gaseous ethylene plus some oxy
some dioxygen molecule which is the the
most prevalent form of oxygen molecule
that you would find in in the atmosphere
and so that's also in the gas form put
them together you end up with some
carbon dioxide gas and some liquid water
this is the classic combustion reaction
but now let's think about how do we
balance this thing let's make sure we
have the same number of each atom on
both sides and when you see something
more complicated like this where you
know here I have an oxygen and two
different in two different molecules
over here and you know a lot of these
molecules have multiple elements in it
it might be very daunting where do I
start and this is where the art of
balancing chemical chemical equation
starts to come into play the general
idea is try to balance the try to
balance the molecules that have multiple
elements in them first and leave the the
the molecules that only have one element
in them for last and the idea there is
is that these are harder they're gonna
have all sorts of implications and then
at the end of the day you can just set a
number here for the number of than for
the number of die oxygens if you saved
if you saved say the ethylene for last
then every time and you're trying to
balance the carbons then when you try to
change the number of carbons you're
gonna change the number of hydrogen's
which is gonna change that you're gonna
have to balance over and over you're
gonna go into this really really really
confusing circle so the best thing to do
try to balance the complex molecules
first and then save the
the single element molecules for last so
let's let's do that so let's start let's
start with the carbons so over here I
have two carbons over here I only have
one carbon I only have one carbon so it
seems like the best way to balance it is
I should have two molecules of carbon
dioxide and I haven't I haven't even
thought about the oxygens yet by putting
that two there that's going to change
the number of oxygens I have on the
right-hand side but at least it balances
my carbons I now have two carbons on the
left-hand side and I have two carbons on
the right-hand side I'm no longer
magically destroying a carbon atom all
right now let's move on to the hydrogens
and remember what I said is let's wait
to do the oxygens last because we have a
molecule that only contains oxygen right
over here so we'll save oxygen for last
so let's do let's do hydrogen next so
hydrogen right over here we have four
hydrogen's and on the right hand side we
have two hydrogen's so it seems like the
easiest thing to do to balance the
hydrogen's is to have two of these water
molecules now I have four hydrogen's
here and I have four hydrogen's there
now let's do the oxygen now let's do the
oxygen I've balanced the carbons and the
hydrogen's and the reason why oxygen is
going to be interesting I can just count
the amount of oxygen I now have here
after throwing these after throat after
changing the number of molecules I have
and then I can adjust this accordingly
because this is only going to affect the
number of oxygens that I have on the
left hand side well right now on the
left hand side I have two oxygens and on
the right hand side let me count this I
have two oh twos really so this is going
to be four oxygens here and then I have
each of these water molecules has one
oxygen but I have two water molecules so
this is going to be two oxygens two
oxygens here so on the right hand side I
have four plus two oxygens so I have six
oxygens on the right hand side I need
six oxygens on the left hand side I need
this number to be six so how do I do
that well I just need three of these
molecules if I have three molecules each
of them have
Oxygen's i'm gonna have a total of six
oxygens and just like that we have
balanced this combustion reaction this
chemical equation